The more you read, the better you read.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here,
and today I want to talk about how
to improve reading comprehension.
Uh, it's a subject, a question that I
get asked quite often, uh, but first, if
you enjoy these videos, please subscribe.
Click on the bell for notifications.
If you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a comment.
Reading comprehension is crucial.
Now, a lot of people actually feel that
they have good reading comprehension,
but they have trouble speaking.
However, there are also a lot of
people who don't have great reading
comprehension, who read slowly,
and this of course  is an obstacle
to improving in the language,
even in our own native language.
The faster we can read, the more quickly
we understand what we're reading, the
faster we can acquire information through
reading and that ability to read, the
speed with which we read, that sort
of functional literacy, that that, uh,
those skills they build on themselves.
It's, it's a bit like the rich get
richer and the poor get poorer.
If you have uh, better reading
skills, you read faster.
As you read faster, you learn more,
you get better at reading and just
get better and better and better.
So how do we, for people who have
trouble reading in the language they're
learning, is there a way to break
that, um, kind of vicious circle?
Well, first thing is to read, as
I just indicated, to be a good
reader, to improve your comp...
reading comprehension,
you have to read a lot.
Okay?
But let's say you have trouble reading.
It could be for any number of reasons.
First of all, if you're reading
in a foreign language, you're not
used to reading in that language.
You may not be used to reading in the,
um, the script, you know, but there again,
the only solution is to do more of it.
You just have to do more of it.
But the other things that I
find helpful are listening.
Okay.
Listening combined with
reading is very powerful.
I find that if I read something, you
know, without, like, without preparation,
I have more difficulty reading it.
If I can listen to it first, I
have an idea of what's there.
I have some momentum.
Momentum even in so far as
the intonation is concerned.
Then I do better when I go to read.
Also, in languages where I have
trouble reading, like Arabic and
Persian, I use LingQ and I go in
sentence mode so that I might go
through the lesson once in sentence
mode and then again in in lesson mode.
But it, it just helps me to focus
in on one sentence at a time.
And then of course, in order to be able
to have good reading comprehension,
you need a large vocabulary because
every time you come across a word that
you don't know, it's, it disturbs you.
You're, you've got a certain
flow and you've got meaning.
And ideally, you want the meaning
to flow into your brain without you
having to translate in your own lang...
into your own language.
And every time you hit a word you
don't know, it slows you down.
You gotta look up the word
you've lost that, uh, momentum.
So building up vocabulary is extremely
important, but in a way it sort
of gets back to the same thing.
In other words, the more you
read, the better you read.
The more you read, the
more words you acquire.
The more words you acquire,
the better you read.
So it's all a virtuous.
You have to continuously sort of put
yourself in front of reading material,
and also I would suggest you vary the
difficulty level between challenging
material, which might have a lot of
new words and easy material that has
very little in the way of new words.
I have found that since my goal is
to become a fluent reader in whatever
language I'm learning, but at the same
time to acquire more words, I have
found that 15% unknown words as we count
them at LingQ is kind of a sweet spot.
I'm acquiring enough new words.
I'm not just reading material
that has all known words.
However, if that sort of unknown words
total is 30%, 25%, it's too difficult.
It slows me down.
I don't develop any genuine
fluency in, uh, in the language.
So to improve your reading comprehension,
read more, increase your vocabulary.
Use audio use tools like, you
know, the sentence view at LingQ.
Immerse yourself more in the language.
If there are structures that give you
trouble, like some people complain
that, you know, in German you've got
the separated verbs, uh, you know, long
sentences with a verb comes at the end.
Or people reading in Japanese that
find that because that those languages
are structured little diff...
differently, it's difficult to read.
True.
But that's all the more reason
why you have to read more.
And that's all the more reason why
you have to listen more, because very
often when you hear those sentences
spoken by the native speaker with a
normal cadence, the normal intonation,
the normal rhythm, it's easier to
understand because the voice of the
narrator of the speaker, putting the
emphasis in the right place makes
those sentences easier to understand.
When you don't have the benefit of that
audio and you're just reading very often
you, you're pushing uphill here, you
don't have that momentum that, that, that
sense of, of, of what the meaning is,
which the narrator will often impart.
So I definitely recommend, particularly
in languages where you find it difficult
to read, because the structure is
so different that you use audio.
By the same token, there are people who
say, I can read, I have no trouble reading
but I don't understand what I hear.
So I think if those people would
also put more emphasis on listening,
like I, I had a good friend who, who
enjoyed reading French literature but
couldn't understand an audio book.
And I said, you should listen to
an audio book that you're reading
so that you get the two working
together to make you a better reader.
Not only better able to understand
spoken, the spoken language, this
happened to be French, but also
that you become a better reader.
So those are some of the things...
I had made some notes, but I can't
remember uh, what I had written down here.
But, uh, you know, it all comes down
to the same, uh, in other words, to
become good at a language, and of
course, the good listening comprehension
leads to good reading comprehension.
Good reading comprehension means
you have a large vocabulary, with
that, you're also going to be able
to speak better, use words better.
It's all tied, it's all interconnected.
So, uh, I hope that's, And, uh, to
improve your reading comprehension.
Read more and use audio to
help you get that momentum
going to improve your reading.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.